D’après les chercheurs en cosmologie, nous serions
actuellement dans un Univers qui non seulement
est en expansion, mais en plus, en expansion
accélérée. Et ce phénomène serait peut-être dû à
une mystérieuse substance, qu’on appelle l’énergie
sombre, et qui conduirait à terme à un grand
déchirement de tout ce qui peuple l’Univers : les
galaxies, les étoiles, les planètes, et nous avec.
Plutôt intrigant, non ? Alors
dans cette vidéo et la suivante,
on va essayer de comprendre ce que signifie cette
histoire d’expansion accélérée de l’Univers,
comment elle a été découverte de façon
plutôt inattendue il y a environ 25
ans. Et on se demandera si on a vraiment
besoin d’énergie sombre pour l’expliquer.
[jingle]
Pour commencer, je vais rappeler ce qu’est
l’expansion de l’Univers «tout court»,
et comment on la concevait avant qu’on ne découvre
ce phénomène d’accélération. Je vais répéter
quelques points que j’ai déjà abordé dans d’autres
vidéos, mais je vais être un peu plus précis que
d’habitude, pour bien pouvoir comprendre,
ensuite, cette histoire d’accélération.
Le phénomène d’expansion de l’Univers a été
découvert en 1929 par l’astronome américain
Edwin Hubble. A l’époque, il observait différentes
galaxies, et s’efforçait de mesurer leur distance
et leur vitesse par rapport à nous. Il avait alors
constaté une chose étonnante : toutes les galaxies
qui nous entourent semblent s’éloigner de nous,
et ce d’autant plus vite qu’elles sont lointaines.
[HUBBLE Hubble avait publié à l’époque ce
diagramme. On y voit la distance en abscisses,
et la vitesse d’éloignement en ordonnées.
Et chaque point représente une galaxie.
Et il semble y avoir une relation de
proportionnalité entre les deux : plus
une galaxie est lointaine, plus
elle s’éloigne vite de nous.
Ce diagramme était assez surprenant, on
aurait pu s’attendre à ce qu’il n’y ait
pas de lien particulier entre la distance et la
vitesse d’une galaxie. Mais non, non seulement
toutes les galaxies s’éloignent, mais en plus
à une vitesse proportionnelle à leur distance.
Avant de creuser l’interprétation de
ce genre de diagramme, il est vraiment
important de comprendre à partir de
quelles types de mesures il a été réalisé.]
Commençons par la distance. De façon générale,
quand on observe un objet astrophysique
et qu’on mesure par exemple sa luminosité,
ça ne nous renseigne pas forcément très
bien sur sa distance par rapport à nous.
Par exemple si la luminosité d’une
étoile dans le ciel est faible,
est-ce que c’est parce qu’elle se trouve loin
de nous, ou bien qu’elle se trouve proche mais
qu’il s’agit d’une étoile qui n’est pas
très puissante ? Pas évident de trancher.
Pour estimer la distance de façon fiable,
il faut des objets dont on connait déjà
par avance la puissance : ce qu’on appelle leur
luminosité intrinsèque. Si vous la connaissez,
alors en mesurant la luminosité apparente,
vous pouvez en déduire leur distance. Des
objets de ce genre, dont on connait par
avance la puissance lumineuse intrinsèque,
on appelle ça des chandelles standard.
A l’époque, Hubble avait utilisé comme
chandelles standards certaines étoiles variables,
dont on connait la puissance intrinsèque
grâce à leur période de variation. Il avait
ainsi pu estimer la distance de quelques
galaxies qui contenaient ce type d’étoiles.
Ensuite, pour mesurer la vitesse, Hubble
avait utilisé un phénomène découvert
quelques années plus tôt : le décalage
vers le rouge des longueurs d’onde.
[DECALAGE En effet, quand on mesure le spectre
lumineux des étoiles d’une galaxie lointaine,
on trouve toujours que les longueurs d’ondes
des raies d’émission ou d’absorption sont
plus grandes que celles qu’on mesure sur Terre.
Pour des longueurs d’ondes de lumière visible,
elles apparaissent décalées vers le rouge.]
A l’époque on interprétait cela comme un
effet Doppler. L’effet Doppler c’est ce
qui fait qu'une sirène de pompiers semble
plus grave quand le camion s’éloigne de
nous. La longueur d’onde du son se trouve
étirée du fait du déplacement de la source.
Et pour les galaxies, on a simplement pensé à
la même chose, avec la lumière au lieu du son.
Le décalage vers le rouge des galaxies
a donc été initialement interprété comme
la conséquence de leur vitesse d’éloignement.
Et c’est quelque chose qu’on peut quantifier.
[DOPPLER REDSHIFT Pour quantifier l’effet Doppler,
on mesure le pourcentage d’augmentation des
longueurs d’onde. Si par exemple toutes les
longueurs d’onde sont 4% plus élevées
que prévu, on dit que le décalage est de
0,04. On le note généralement z, et on utilise
parfois le terme anglo-saxon de redshift.
Et on peut l’interpréter en disant
que la source lumineuse se déplaçait
à ce pourcentage de la vitesse de la lumière,
sur mon exemple, 4% de 300 000 ça fait 12000
km/s. Donc de façon générale, selon cette
interprétation, mesurer le décalage des
longueurs d’onde donne une idée de la
vitesse de la galaxie par rapport à nous.]
Ce qu’on verra par la suite, c’est
que cette interprétation «effet
Doppler» qu’on avait à l’époque, elle
est en fait incorrecte. Pour la suite,
il faut donc se souvenir que ce qu’on mesure
vraiment ça n’est pas directement la vitesse,
mais ce redshift noté z. Et donc en
toute rigueur on devrait plutôt graduer
le diagramme en utilisant z plutôt
que la vitesse qu’on en a déduite.
[DIAGRAMME HUBBLE2 Depuis les travaux de Hubble,
on a pu mesurer beaucoup plus de galaxies,
de plus en plus lointaines, et ainsi
confirmer cette relation de proportionnalité
entre distance et vitesse, ou plutôt entre la
distance et le z. On voit ici des mesures bien
plus récentes, et les observations initiales de
Hubble correspondraient seulement à la toute
petite zone dans le coin en bas à gauche.
Mais la relation de proportionnalité semble bien
solide, et la constante de proportionnalité,
c’est ce qu’on appelle la constante de Hubble.]
Bien, c’est donc cette observation de
l’éloignement des galaxies les unes par
rapport aux autres qui est à la base de l’idée
d’expansion de l’Univers. Les mesures d’Hubble
et de ses successeurs semblent nous
dire qu’actuellement l’Univers est
effectivement en expansion, et à
un rythme que l’on peut mesurer.
Une question naturelle qu’on peut se poser,
c’est : est-ce que cette expansion s’est
toujours faite au même rythme ? Est-ce
que dans le passé elle était plus faible,
plus forte ? Ce que vous savez sans doute, c’est
qu’en astrophysique, plus on regarde loin, plus
on regarde dans le passé de l’Univers, puisque la
lumière a mis un certain temps à nous parvenir.
[HUBBLE2 Mais sur le diagramme de Hubble que
je vous ai montré, on n’a pas été assez loin
pour remonter suffisamment dans le passé. On
voit qu’on a des galaxies situées à environ
un milliards d’années lumières. Leur lumière
a donc été émise il y a 1 milliard d’années.]
Mais l’Univers est âgé de 13.8 milliards d’années,
donc il y a 1 milliard d’années il n’était
pas si différent d’aujourd’hui. Ce diagramme
de Hubble nous renseigne surtout sur
le présent, pas tellement sur le passé.
Pour reconstituer l’état de l’Univers
il y a plusieurs milliards d’années,
on ne se base pas sur ces mesures directement,
mais on utilise des modèles théoriques de
l’expansion de l’Univers. Et il se trouve
que ceux-ci ont été élaborés à peu près à la
même époque que les découvertes de Hubble.
[jingle]
Dans les années 1920, deux scientifiques, le russe
Alexander Friedmann et le belge Georges Lemaître
mettent au point indépendamment les premiers
modèles cosmologiques, en se basant sur les
équations de la relativité générale, établies
une dizaine d’années plus tôt par Einstein.
Et très vite, même avant la découverte de
Hubble, Lemaître réalise que ces équations
impliquent que l’Univers puisse être en
expansion, et il devine que cela doit se
manifester par une relation entre la
vitesse et la distance des galaxies.
Hubble ne connaissait pas à
l’époque les travaux de Lemaitre,
mais on peut dire que ce dernier l’avait
en quelque sorte devancé par ses calculs,
et d’ailleurs on appelle maintenant cette relation
de proportionnalité la loi de Hubble-Lemaître.
[FACTEUR D’ECHELLE Pour établir leurs modèles
cosmologiques, Friedman et Lemaître raisonnent
sur une quantité très importante qu’on
appelle le facteur d’échelle de l’Univers,
et qu’on note «petit a». Il s’agit
d’un nombre qui évolue au cours du temps,
et qui représente l’échelle des distances dans
l’Univers, rapportée aux distances actuelles.
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ? Actuellement
par définition le facteur d’échelle vaut 1.
Imaginons deux galaxies situées aujourd’hui à
une distance de 200 millions d’années-lumière.
Dans le passé, quand le facteur d’échelle était
plus faible, disons 0.5, elle n’étaient distantes
que de la moitié, 100 millions. Et si un
jour le facteur d’échelle vaut disons 2.5,
elle seront 2.5 fois plus éloignées
qu’aujourd’hui, à 500 millions d’années lumière.]
Le facteur d’échelle est donc la quantité
importante qui décrit l’évolution de la
géométrie de l’Univers, et nous renseigne sur
les distances entre les galaxies. Et ce que
permettent de faire les équations de Friedman et
Lemaître, c’est de quantifier cette évolution au
cours du temps, à la fois pour reconstituer le
passé, mais aussi pour extrapoler vers le futur.
[COURBE Ce qu’on veut, c’est donc
tracer cette courbe : l’évolution
du facteur d’échelle «petit a» au cours
du temps. On l’a dit aujourd’hui, il vaut
1 par définition. Et par convention aujourd’hui
c’est le temps zéro, donc on est à ce point là.
Mais on connait aussi la pente de l’évolution du
facteur d’échelle, puisque la constante de Hubble
quantifie l’expansion actuelle de l’Univers.
Donc on connait aussi ça. Mais juste avec ce
petit morceau de courbe, on ne sait pas ce
qu’il s’est passé avant, ou se passera après.
Mais les équations de Friedman-Lemaître
permettent justement de le reconstituer,
et de proposer des scénarios qui respectent
les équations de la relativité générale. En
voici quelques uns représentés, et
ils ont des allures différentes.
On voit que dans certains cas
le facteur d’échelle augmentera,
passera par un maximum et diminuera ensuite
jusqu’à zéro. Cela signifie que l’Univers
finira par se recontracter et terminera dans
ce qu’on appelle un Big Crunch. Et puis,
pour d’autres scénarios, l’expansion
continuera à l’infini, l’Univers se
diluera et se refroidira indéfiniment,
dans ce qu’on appelle parfois un Big Chill.
Ce qui différencie ces différents
scénarios, c’est la densité de matière
et d’énergie présente dans l’Univers. Si
elle est suffisamment élevée on aura un
scénario en Big Crunch. Et si elle est trop
faible, une expansion éternelle en Big Chill.
Cela fait un éventail de possibilités,
mais une chose qu’on peut toutefois
remarquer sur ces courbes, c’est que
l’expansion est toujours en décélération.
Même dans le cas d’une expansion qui sera
éternelle, la pente de la courbe s’aplatit
de plus en plus au cours du temps. Donc
même si elle continue indéfiniment,
l’expansion est toujours de moins en
moins forte, elle n’accélère jamais.]
Pour mieux comprendre ces différents
scénarios, on peut prendre une analogie.
[PROJECTILE Imaginez que vous soyez au 10e
étage d’un immeuble à regarder par la fenêtre,
et vous voyez passer devant vos yeux un projectile
en train de partir verticalement vers le ciel.
Supposons que vous puissiez mesurer la vitesse
du projectile quand il passe devant vos yeux.
Ce projectile peut avoir deux destins : soit
il va monter jusqu’à une certaine hauteur puis
redescendre vers le sol. Soit il va continuer,
s’arracher de l’attraction terrestre et partir
dans l’espace. Cela dépend de sa vitesse actuelle
et de la force de gravité. Mais dans les deux cas,
le projectile est forcément en décélération.
Sa vitesse d’éloignement ne peut que décroitre.
Et si vous voulez estimer sa décélération,
vous ne pouvez pas mesurer juste la vitesse
quand il passe devant vous. Il
faut un point de comparaison,
par exemple la mesurer aussi un peu plus bas
sur sa trajectoire, et faire la différence.]
Eh bien pour l’Univers c’est pareil, si on
veut savoir comment il va évoluer, on ne peut
pas se contenter de regarder le présent, car
toutes les courbes sont similaires dans les
différents modèles. Il faut aussi être capable de
regarder suffisamment dans le passé pour voir les
différences. Et regarder dans le passé, on
l’a dit, ça se fait en regardant plus loin.
[HUBBLE2 Tout à l’heure quand j’ai
montré le diagramme de Hubble,
je vous ai dit qu’à peu de choses près,
il ne nous renseignait que sur l’état
actuel de l’Univers, car il ne regardait
pas d’objets astrophysiques suffisamment
lointains. Pour espérer distinguer quelque
chose, il faut prolonger ce diagramme.
Ce que l’on sait, c’est que cette
loi de proportionnalité de Hubble,
qui relie la distance et le décalage
z, n’est qu’approximative. Si on va
à des valeurs de z suffisamment
grandes, on commencera à avoir
des déviations qui nous permettront de
discriminer les différents scénarios.]
Tout à l’heure vous vous en souvenez, j’ai parlé
de vitesse, d’effet Doppler et je vous ai dit
qu’il fallait prendre cette interprétation
avec des pincettes. Car ça n’est pas ça,
la véritable explication physique du décalage
des longueurs d’onde. Et si on essaye d’aller
justement regarder des galaxies avec des décalages
élevés, cette subtilité devient importante.
[DOPPLER vs REDSHIFT Dans l’effet Doppler, tel
qu’il se produit pour le son, on a une onde
qui se déplace dans un certain milieu matériel,
l’air, et une source qui se déplace par rapport
à ce milieu. On peut voir la longueur d’onde du
son comme la distance qui sépare deux crêtes du
signal sonore. Or ces deux crêtes sont émises
par la source à un certain intervalle de temps.
Donc si la source se déplace légèrement
entre l’émission des deux crêtes,
la distance entre les deux va se trouver
allongée par rapport à la normale,
donc la longueur d’onde sera plus importante et
le son plus grave que prévu. Et le pourcentage
d’allongement sera le ratio de la vitesse
de la source divisée par la vitesse du son.
Avec l’expansion de l’Univers, c’est
différent. L’origine du décalage vers
le rouge, c’est que la longueur d’onde de la
lumière, la distance entre les deux crêtes,
augmente au cours du temps du fait de l’expansion
de l’Univers. La longueur d’onde se dilate.
Ça n’est donc pas un phénomène de décalage qui
se produit au moment de l’émission de lumière,
comme pour l’effet Doppler, mais c’est
un effet qui s’accumule progressivement
pendant tout le trajet de l’onde
lumineuse jusqu’à sa destination.]
Pour connaitre l’intensité
du décalage, c’est simple,
on applique le principe d’expansion des
distances, c’est-à-dire qu’on regarde
comment a changé le facteur d’échelle
le temps du trajet de la lumière.
[REDSHIFT Imaginons une galaxie que l’on observe,
et dont la lumière ait été émise quand le
facteur d’échelle de l’Univers n’était que
de 2/3. Aujourd’hui le facteur d’échelle est
1, donc il a augmenté de 50%. Les longueurs
d’onde seront donc toutes augmentées de
50%, c’est ce qu’on appelle un z de 0.5.
Maintenant imaginez une lumière que l’on
capte aujourd’hui mais qui a été émise
quand le facteur d’échelle était 1/3, vu
d’aujourd’hui, cela fera un triplement de
la longueur d’onde, donc une augmentation
de 200%. Ca correspond à un z égal à 2. Et
si on remonte encore plus loin dans le passé
de l’Univers, z peut être encore plus grand.]
Je vous rappelle que dans une interprétation
Doppler, le décalage z, c’est la vitesse de
la source par rapport à la vitesse de la
lumière. z=2, ça voudrait dire une vitesse
d’éloignement qui serait le double de la vitesse
de la lumière. C’est compliqué à justifier.
Avec la bonne interprétation du décalage
vers le rouge, vous voyez que mesurer
z à partir d’un spectre lumineux, cela
permet de connaitre non pas une vitesse,
mais directement la valeur du facteur
d’échelle au moment de l’émission de la
lumière. Ca nous renseigne donc sur l’état de
l’Univers à ce moment là. Et grâce à ça, en
regardant suffisamment loin, on doit pouvoir faire
le tri entre les différents modèles cosmologiques.
[DIAGRAMMES Ici je vous ai remis en
différentes couleurs à gauche les
évolutions possibles du facteur d’échelle
en fonction des différents modèles,
les courbes les plus foncées correspondant à
des densités moyennes de l’Univers plus élevées.
Et à droite je vous ai mis ce qu’on devrait
observer pour le diagramme de Hubble selon ces
différents modèles si on arrive à observer des
objets astrophysiques suffisamment lointains,
avec des z élevés. On peut voir ça
comme un diagramme de Hubble étendu.
Vous voyez qu’à faible distance et faible
redshift, les courbes sont toutes confondues.
Et les mesures qu’on avait jusqu’ici pour
le diagramme de Hubble étaient dans ce coin
là. Mais si on va mesurer à des distances
importantes et des z suffisamment élevés,
proches de 1 par exemple, on peut commencer
à savoir dans quel scénario on se trouve.
Ici, plus la courbe est haute, plus la
décélération de l’Univers est forte,
donc plus il y a de matière dans l’Univers.
Inversement plus la courbe est basse,
plus la décélération est faible, et moins il y a
de matière. La courbe en pointillés noir, c’est
le cas limite où il n’y aurait aucune matière
dans l’Univers, et donc aucune décélération.]
Voilà, on a donc un moyen expérimental de
savoir dans lequel des scénarios on se trouve,
en complétant le diagramme de
Hubble par des observations
suffisamment lointaines. Il n’y a plus qu’à !
[jingle]
Et justement dans les années 90, deux équipes
de recherche se sont formées avec l’ambition
d’étendre le diagramme de Hubble pour
pouvoir lever cette incertitude : la
collaboration High-Z et la collaboration
SNC, pour Supernova Cosmology Project.
Ces deux équipes, qui étaient de fait en
concurrence, avaient pour objectif initial de
mesurer la décélération de l’Univers en utilisant
des supernovas lointaines. Les supernovas,
et notamment celles qu’on appelle de type Ia,
sont en effet des explosions d’étoiles qui
constituent des chandelles standards, car elles
se produisent toujours selon le même scénario.
[SUPERNOVA Vous voyez ici une vue d’artiste du
phénomène. Quand une étoile naine blanche se
trouve proche d’une autre étoile dont elle
peut chiper la matière, elle la dépouille
progressivement et grossit. Mais quand la
naine blanche atteint une masse assez précise,
environ 1.4 fois la masse du Soleil, une explosion
thermonucléaire ultra-violente se déclenche.
La luminosité intrinsèque de l’explosion est
absolument colossale, et évolue selon une courbe
bien connue et calibrée. On peut donc à partir
de sa luminosité apparente estimer la distance
de la supernova. Et en bonus, comme l’explosion
est incroyablement puissante, ces supernovas
peuvent être observées dans des galaxies très
distantes, plusieurs milliards d’années lumières.]
La difficulté, c’est que ces événements sont
très transitoires et très rares, il ne se produit
que quelques supernovas par millénaire dans une
galaxie typique. Nos deux équipes de chercheurs
ont donc mis en place des méthodes de surveillance
de larges portions du ciel, permettant de repérer
le maximum de supernovas, sans savoir à
l’avance où elles allaient se produire.
En 1998, les deux collaborations ont quasi
simultanément annoncé leurs résultats. Et là, ce
fut une surprise ! Alors qu’elles étaient parties
pour mesurer la décélération de l’expansion de
l’Univers, les deux ont indépendamment découvert
que l’expansion était en fait en accélération.
[DIAGRAMMES Souvenez-vous de ce
diagramme, à droite, qui représente
la distance en fonction du décalage z
dans les modèles de Friedman-Lemaitre,
et qui diffèrent par la densité de matière.
Densité élevée pour les courbes les plus basses,
densité faible pour celles au-dessus, et en
pointillée la limite extrême d’une densité nulle.
Eh bien les observations de supernova ont
montré qu’elles se situaient ici. Dans une
zone impossible à expliquer par un Univers
en décélération. Et donc aucun des modèles
d’évolution du facteur d’échelle représentés
à gauche ne peut être correct. Il faut trouver
autre chose, qui soit compatible avec ces
nouvelles données d’expansion accélérée.]
Pour cette découverte inattendue, les deux équipes
ont reçu en 2011 le prix Nobel de Physique. Alors
je dit les équipes, en fait le prix Nobel de
physique est toujours décerné à des personnes,
et jamais plus que 3. Donc ce sont les
leaders des collaborations qui l’ont eu,
mais évidemment cela récompense
le travail des équipes entières.
Évidemment cette découverte a renvoyé
les théoriciens à leurs calculs,
pour essayer de comprendre comment
l’Univers pouvait être en expansion
accélérée, alors qu’on envisageait plutôt
jusqu’ici des modèles en décélération.
[DIAGRAMMES Alors j’exagère un peu en
le présentant comme ça. En pratique,
on n’a pas eu trop de mal à proposer de
nouveaux modèles qui collent, car ces
phénomènes d’expansion accélérée avaient déjà
été envisagés et étudiés sur le plan théorique.
Il en existe plusieurs variantes, mais
toutes prédisent une évolution du facteur
d’échelle de ce genre : une expansion
éternelle et de plus en plus forte,
qui finira par tout déchirer avec elle,
ce qu’on appelle parfois un Big Rip.]
Sur le plan théorique, il existe plusieurs
façon d’obtenir une telle évolution,
et dans la prochaine vidéo,
on verra plus précisément
ces différentes hypothèses susceptibles
d’expliquer cette expansion accélérée. On
essaiera notamment de comprendre ce
qu’est cette mystérieuse énergie sombre
qui composerait soi-disant 70% de l’Univers,
et on se demandera si on en a vraiment besoin.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui,
merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo,
abonnez vous pour augmenter vos chances
de voir passer les prochaines vidéos,
rejoignez le Discord de Science
étonnante pour prolonger la discussion,
le lien est en description, et je vous dit à
très vite pour la prochaine vidéo. A bientôt.